[Music]
huh
you called lieutenant lollipop and
Sergeant snuggles let me tell you
something babe yeah you're gonna get
cute cute law enforcement here's what's
gonna happen if you call me if you call
lieutenant lollipop and Sergeant
snuggles to the crime scene what's gonna
happen is first of all I'm gonna shoot a
gun that has bubbles that you can burst
second of all if anybody gets out of
line what they're gonna do it's gonna
get a blow pop in their mouth and I'm
gonna kiss them softly on their belly
button jerked them off until they calm
down and sergeants Sarge you sir
disturbers will be right there with
lieutenant lollipop and guess what I'm
handing out I'm handing out kisses on
the butt that's right Toshi I'm giving
you two she kisses I'm pulling down your
pants and I'm doing a nice little pack
pack on the left cheek yeah you're gonna
you're gonna walk away not know what
happened but I I'll tell you what you
won't do again yeah that's commit a
crime
we are lieutenant lollipop and Sergeant
starburst yeah here's the situation well
we get to the crime scene okay yeah we
got a new way of policing babe where you
get kissed on the mouth
you get tickled to death and also
[ __ ] we kiss you on the ass cheeks
and make no mistake we're gonna be
training law enforcement this country
over it will eliminate crime because
when you get kissed on the ass cheeks
the last thing you're gonna want to do
is see our faces again to kiss you on
your ass because tell me this when
lieutenant lollipop and Sergeant
snuggles show up to the crime scene if I
just start jerking everybody off tell me
how the situation is gonna do anything
else but deescalate if I'm just jerking
them off and then I start jerking off
till what are you gonna [ __ ] do when
I come in there and I start Eskimo
kissing your belly button you're gonna
put down the weapon yeah I mean you know
the truth is the truth is that that
policing is probably gonna be more
effective and policing by force yeah
because guys will really be like you'll
make it to [ __ ] off but you're gonna be
like knock head lay right down my
partner's gonna jerk you off will I kiss
your ass cheeks and that's your [ __ ]
punishment and he's gonna be like please
stop I'm never gonna steal again yeah
damn right you are because if you do
[ __ ] lollipop and Starbucks are gonna
come and we're gonna fondle your face
that's what it is cuz you want to steal
from this store one more time lieutenant
I'm just gonna come in and tickle your
nutsack because would you boot would you
blow on somebody's ear if we if we
arresting the kid if lieutenant loud pop
and Sergeant stores come by and this is
a repeat offender we come
we've already jerked them off and we've
already kissed him on the ass cheeks
yeah what are we gonna do what are we
gonna do for a second time offender for
a second how do you up the ante from
[ __ ] blowing the guy for a second
time offender what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna have you put him in handcuffs I'm
gonna have you wrestle them down put my
hair cuz make no mistake you put on
about 30 pounds you jack
you're an F F or what the gay community
calls a bear so you're gonna wrestle and
I'm gonna save his lap and I'm gonna
softly sing him verses from the 1975
until he cries and tells me he's never
gonna do it again yeah that's how you up
the end I dick the way we up the ideas
I'm gonna put on I'm gonna put on some
Taylor Swift some of her faster songs
yeah and you're gonna give the guy lap
dance getting a lap dance from you let
me tell you something if cops showed up
to my apartment all right and he said
hello my name is lieutenant lollipop I
heard there was a domestic disturbance
in this apartment I said they're sorry
officer I just had the distance with my
wife because the sauce was a little off
yeah and you're gonna go okay look I
would normally take you down to the
station but now we're doing a different
type of policing and somebody flicked on
Pandora and put on Taylor Swift and you
put out that you don't you you have you
have what they call a can't scoot around
you but yeah you got you're not you're a
guy a guy if you're in my way I can't
get around you I can't scoot by you
you're gonna have to remove yourself
from that geographic location so I can
get by on I got the kind of but when I
sit in the movie theater I'm sitting
there for the whole movie because if I
get up and scoop I'm gonna be knocking
out popcorns people gonna get butt
cheeks to the face with me if I gotta go
a little peepee so usually I just sit
down in a movie theater where it died
yeah if you came over started give me a
[ __ ] lap dance and then actually made
full contact and sat on me and I got
that [ __ ] that jelly butt on me I'd
say officer I will take whatever sauce
my wife makes I've never discipline her
again just please don't [ __ ] sit on
me with that bubble but from now on if
you are in a situation when you need to
call the police do not down down 1-1
instead just either join the patron at
patreon.com slash Bay Ridge Boys or send
us an email at the rpi patron at
gmail.com and tell us what your
situation is and lieutenant Lee pop and
Sergeant snuggles aka Sergeant starburst
will show up we will show up to the
crime scene and we will fight it and if
one of us does make a mistake that make
no mistake vanity our Police
Commissioner will step down or she will
handle because she's then attea but
she's also joseph garbles to propaganda
minister yeah and look at the
if you're if you're someone who just
completely is living a life of crime
just-just-just
I'm talking to parents now okay or I'm
talking to the Guardians or whatever or
parole officers if you can't straighten
a guy out call [ __ ] lieutenant
lollipop and Sergeant starburst and
here's what we'll do if you want a
long-term plan to straighten somebody
else guess what we're doing we're coming
over your house and we're all we're
getting in your bed and we're snuggling
with you all night for seven days
straight yeah you telling me after seven
days straight of a [ __ ] snuggle what
with lieutenant lollipop and Sergeant
starbursts you'll never return cause I'm
I'm gonna chain you into your bed at
bein yawn you're gonna be on either side
snuggling and all you're gonna be able
to do is eat black-and-white cookies and
we're gonna be pumping Whitney Houston
and the only movie playing on repeat is
gonna be Anna Green Gables so you tell
me if you can handle that for a week and
if you want to commit more crimes cuz
that's what it is with lieutenant Harley
pop it sergeant we just solve police
reform thank you guys for watching don't
forget to subscribe also turn on alerts
more to come tell Frau absolutely and go
to patreon.com/crashcourse to join the
matriarchy where things get really wild
[Music]